okay so one of the overarching ideas
that I took away from listening to the
space um and a lot of my notes sort of
you know draw me to this I might as well
get to this sort of early on because I
think it's part of the reason why the
three of us are here today um if if the
church and if the Christ pill is the
answer then why is the church so filled
with plugged in beta males and sooys soy
boys like I've said before I think
churches today are pretty much beta
factories you're not wrong about that
and I think it's an absolute failure of
the church leadership that haven't
hasn't properly um explained and broken
down what Biblical masculinity is um and
broken down the go ahead so how can we
endorse the church the Bible and the
Christ pill if the people in that space
the vast majority of the people in that
space anyway
are they don't look like that they could
punch their way out of a wet paper bag
if I'm being honest like if the
hits a fan I wouldn't want them on my
team for sure and but that's part of the
inspiration as to why stepped into the
space and um you know Chase is you know
Fame speaks for itself as well as and
that was kind of the Gap I was trying to
fill not that I'm some like role model
people should should look up to my whole
role in this in this space is to be a
compass that points people to Christ
points people to the gospel and and
lives as an example of biblical manhood
because it's sorely lacking I think
there that's the problem is that there's
an effeminacy that has metastasized it's
made its way into the church and
feminism has really gripped the church
in in you know we're talking about in
terms of Staff Authority teachings and
there's this absolute ignorance and blat
uh blatant um Turning Away of the
reality of female sin so going back to
your original point about should men get
married young yes however they should be
well equipped an understanding female
biological nature and it's all there in
the text it's just the church leaders
have failed to uh make men understand
what this is is not to pedestalize a
female it's to not have this blue pill
Disneyland version of love that she's
just going to love you forever by virtue
of you just existing and being a sweater
vest wearing Ned Flanders nerd you got
to be a man you got to be a man in
motion you got to be a man that's not
afraid of laying the law down and being
a patriarch and all of those principles
come from the Bible they just haven't
been properly explained and if these
things are properly explained and men
can digest this young then they would be
wise to go on and not burn with lust and
think that they have to acquire all of
the sexual experience which I as a man
that has done that been there done that
I can tell you it doesn't add any value
to my marriage with my wife that's for
sure so I think it was um mentioned
during your live as well that the church
is at the point now where it censors its
own verses for example women must submit
to their men somebody made the point
during that live that that Happ that
exists in the Bible but the church is
now censoring certain verses or removing
you know the original text to sort of
modernize it yeah so that that
someone specified that that happens in
the novas Ordo mass in the Catholic
church right and the novas Ordo Mass was
instituted I believe after Vatican 2
which was a reform in the 60s to the
Catholic Church a major major reform
within the Catholic
church and you know that's that's an
interesting rabbit hole because uh I'm
not a Catholic Rich I'm I'm just a
non-denominational Protestant somebody
who's been following the word on my own
for the past nine years in my walk with
Christ but I've been looking into
Catholicism
and and it looks like something happened
in the 60s with Vatican 2 where a lot of
the uh the the legit foundations of
Christianity kind of got subverted um
from an Outsiders perspective looking in
and part of that subversion ended up
being the removal of those verses saying
that you know wives should submit to
their husbands like they just don't read
those apparently in these masses and I
want to I want to make something clear
too
like when when Mike and I and other
Christian men are saying the Christ pill
is the solution we're not just simply
saying hey if everybody just goes to
church and gets married and finds a
woman at church everything's going to
work out perfectly fine like we're in
complete agreement we talked about this
a lot in the space we're in complete
agreement that the the state of the
modern church is a complete mess and it
is not teaching men how to be men it's
not teaching women how to be women it's
the the church has become very
gynocentric in the modern world and like
you said it's it's kind of like a beta
Factory and uh I I shared the anecdote
one of my friends that I met at the gym
here in town he started going to a
couple local churches after him and I
met and he was like dude I can't find a
single guy at any of these churches that
looks like he can do a pull-up and that
that is the state of the modern church
and it's a huge problem uh so we're not
saying like yeah look just go to church
and and you're G to find the perfect
woman and you're never going to have any
any marital problems what I'm proposing
is the Bible in informs us about human
nature it informs us about God's design
for the Sexes and how what a woman's
Achilles heel is which is the desire to
rule over her husband this was God's
curse to Eve after she ate the fruit in
the garden he cursed woman to desire to
rule over her husband and he cursed man
to have to work to provide for himself
and his loved ones but God also gave men
the duty to lead their families and he
gave women the duty to submit to their
husbands right that is the proper
ordering of the Sexes this is what I the
huge problem with that though today is
you've probably noticed even on the
whatever podcast when you're co-hosting
that is there's a lot of um I mean the
vast majority of women will not submit
to a man of
course absolutely what's the remedy for
that well so the remedy for that is
twofold first off we have to make men
great again I mean we have to we have to
make men worthy of I'm trying Chase but
they're not all listening
I'm trying to it's it's a difficult
fight uh we we've got to make men great
again and there's many different facets
to that process um but men have to
become inherently worthy of
respect they have to become worthy of
commanding and and and earning respect
from women and many men today are not
capable of doing that and then second of
all the thing about submission within
the Bible so obviously rich as you know
submission happen s naturally for a
woman when she respects and looks up to
a man it's not a process that she has to
like bend over backwards to try and do
if you are effectively leading a woman
it's not going to be painful for her to
submit to you she's going to want to
however obviously in any relationship
there's going to be times where uh she's
you know you might falter in your
leadership or what maybe you have a weak
moment whatever she doesn't want to
follow your
leadership the the the value of the
biblical command for women to submit an
authen authentically Christian woman a
woman who actually has firm conviction
in biblical values knows that it's her
duty to submit even when she doesn't
want to you'd be surprised man you talk
to Christian women that like like I I
was speaking to this very traditional
Christian girl last year raised in a
very traditional household her father is
the patriarch of her family and her
mother knows it's her duty to submit to
her
father submission to her like she was
born and raised to know like this this
is my duty as a woman and if we get
married that's what I'm going to do even
if I don't feel like it or want to do it
that's what I'm going to do and that's I
think that's the two-prong solution
that's my opinion I don't know what Mike
has to say no I totally agree I think
that being worthy of submission which
could easily be you know your that serve
the wife mentality which is not what I'm
talking about what I mean by true
patriarchy means you've submitted
yourself to God's command first which he
calls us to rule over our families
patriarchy literally means rule by
fathers right so being a man that's
worth his salt being a man in this world
not of this world according to God's
rule because I think absent of Christ
and those virtues and those principles
it's hard to make an argument for True
masculinity anyways Temperance restraint
Authority patriarchy and then from there
it creates the argument this is my
problem with the red pill as well is
that it is just a biological argument
yes a lot of these things can be correct
just like men have millions of sperm and
we're built to sort of like procreate
endlessly but it it it completely IGN
the fact that we Are Spiritual Beings
and so when a woman is under that
spiritual protection of God and her
husband she understands that and it
transcends her nature to rebel against
you like that's the spirit of Eve and
for the spirit of man or Adam it's a
spirit of passivity so a man sort of
abdicates his role and kind of just like
Adam blindly staring at Eve when she was
in the garden and taking that bite um
she understands that although she has
these feelings and these emotions they
don't always have to be catered to like
my wife knows I don't always have to
hold space for
her because that's complete nonsense
it's it's anti-biblical there's
times where I do where I see fit and I
think it's relevant and that's onto my
judgment because I don't answer to her I
answer to God and she understands
because she respects God first that it's
her duty to submit and as a as a man if
I have to say submit to me woman I've
already lost that's got that that
foundation's got to be there already
does she always submit to you does she
always I mean there's been times where
there there has certainly been some conf
be like hey he's watching no no it just
depends on the situation right if if
they notice there's that you know that
human female emotion coming up I know
how to quell that in a way that's that
does not make me turn to my anger and my
human emotion I just I stay calm I'm
clear and I'm articulate and that's the
way to really speak Authority without
having to be an angry Tyrant about
it it's staying sober minded in those
points of conflict and this is why in
Ephesians when it says women submit to
your husbands It also says you know men
love your wives and so loving my wife
means quote unquote putting her in that
place when she needs to not from a place
of anger but from a place of Grace and
most of the time from a place of
calmness but there is a place for that
righteous anger as well I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out